[Música]
en provenza el azul profundo del
mediterráneo le hace eco al océano azul
violeta de los campos de lavanda en el
interior del país esta cultura
practicada desde la antigüedad romana
sigue siendo el orgullo de muchas
familias en la región
en particular las que viven en el
pequeño pueblo de balón sol
[Aplausos]
estos comerciantes llevan la lavanda en
la sangre desde hace varias generaciones
la abuela que viene ahí era la madre de
mi padre ellos la cortaban a mano mi
abuela lo cortaba en las colinas y
tajibo un golpeo
llegó mi suegro con unos amigos crearon
la destilería imagina marido se hizo
cargo con mi suegro
aquí la lavanda es la estrella de la
tienda
tiene 100 presentaciones diferentes en
peluches jabones bolsitas y sobre todo
como aceite esencial
yo les ofrezco la botella pequeña sirve
para los cortes y las mordeduras
si uno se tuerce el tobillo tiene tantas
propiedades que es casi como la pequeña
farmacia del caminante
la lavanda vendida en su tienda proviene
directamente de su cultivo familiar
trabajan con una vieja cortadora de 1973
apegados a las tradiciones estos
productores dejan los fardos dos días en
el campo antes de destilar los
es un viejo método es el método que
surgió después de la voz somos unos de
los últimos en hacerlo así claro es más
trabajo luego uno se casa más pero bueno
es apasionante y trabajamos con un buen
equipo entonces nos lo tomamos bien
en nuestro aceite las personas que
compran los aceites prefieren éste es
más perfumado además el trabajo no es el
mismo que con los nuevos procedimientos
sin duda nosotros nos tomamos el tiempo
para cortar para destilar y ellos en un
día producen cantidades industriales
en el mundo de la lavanda aunque algunos
siguen apegados a las tradiciones otros
tienen como objetivo las tecnologías
modernas me las arreglé con el
constructor para hacer este prototipo de
cuatro higueras que es en realidad la
trituradora de lava team
más grande del mundo
el lavandín es un híbrido de la lavanda
la meseta de ballan sol es el primer
productor mundial de esta variedad que
es mucho más productiva que la planta
natural
al cortar cuatro hileras de lavandina a
la vez esta máquina recoge 20 hectáreas
por día 8 veces más que una cortadora
tradicional
es verdad que hoy en día es un poco más
agotador mentalmente hay un poco más de
estrés pero el trabajo no es nada uno
está en una cabina aclimatada con
material moderno
[Música]
en el caso de este productor en la
bandina es acumulado directamente en
estos contenedores para ir de inmediato
a la destilería se pone una tapa sobre
los contenedores que se vuelven entonces
unas enormes ollas a presión en la
bandina es calentado a altas
temperaturas
los granos liberan su aroma
después de haberse enfriado el aceite
esencial es separado del agua en el
esencia door
aquí tenemos extracto natural de
lavandina
hacemos un producto 100% natural
como pueden ver
es igual que en todas las destilerías
y tenemos la banda en 100% puro
los productores no son los únicos en
busca de este oro azul
vamos a tratar de atrapar una abeja
los campos deberán sol
también atrae en el ojo de los artistas
está diseñadora de origen alemán se
enamoró de provenza donde vive desde
hace 20 años
en realidad lo que más me gusta es
cuando hay sombra cuando hay un juego de
luces
lo importante es encontrar el ángulo
correcto el ine observa veo más o mejor
las líneas si estoy arriba que si estoy
abajo
la mitad de bala un sol
también atrae fotógrafos aficionados
mujeres chinas tan entusiasmadas al ver
el primer campo de lavanda
que a veces causan accidentes
las fotos de estas turistas no son
tomadas por azar todas tratan con más o
menos éxito de imitar a su estrella la
heroína de una serie china vista por 200
millones de telespectadores la historia
de una luna de miel en francia donde la
lavanda juega un papel esencial desde
entonces el pueblo de balón sol es
conocido en el mundo entero
cada año atrae decenas de miles de
turistas de todos los rincones
[Música]